[Música]
bienvenidos a esta especial cultura
dedicado a la protección de nuestra
memoria en esencia es lo que contienen
los sitios monumentos y piezas de arte
cada vez más en peligro al ser objetivo
de conflictos armados desgobiernos e
incluso la crisis climática su
destrucción no es nueva ha sido una
táctica histórica de territorios y
estados pero nuestro siglo la han
alimentado actores y grupos como el
talibán cuyo retorno amenaza el acervo
de afganistán a dos décadas de su ataque
a los budas de bamiyán hacemos balance
de las pérdidas la ilegalidad y
desmembración social que rodea a nuestro
patrimonio
esta es una de las imágenes más
recordadas de la destrucción de
patrimonio
los talibanes borraron en 2001 los budas
de bamiyán con el único fin de eliminar
de afganistán la cultura no islámica hoy
el gobierno del grupo revive los temores
sobre la conservación empezando por lo
inmaterial como la música los ataques
culturales en zonas de guerra han sido
una práctica histórica desde la
destrucción de la biblioteca de
alejandría hasta los bombardeos nazis
durante la segunda guerra mundial pero
en el siglo 21 otros factores y actores
han seguido este terror repetimos y el
patrimonio se enfrenta a 13 conflicto
cambio climático y crimen o corrupción
tráfico ilícito y el conflicto puede
dañar el patrimonio y yo diría que de
tres maneras ya sea porque el patrimonio
es un daño colateral porque es un
objetivo o porque también es un arma de
guerra el segundo tema es el cambio
climático tiene un impacto muy fuerte en
el patrimonio y en particular a través
de la desertificación como vemos en el
sahel
a través del último y finalmente la
última cuestión es lo que llamaré delito
es decir tanto la corrupción que puede
conducir a una urbanización excesiva
como también el tráfico ilícito y el
saqueo de bienes culturales que socavan
el patrimonio
apóstata a su patrimonio en los últimos
años las acciones más impactantes han
sido ejecutadas por actores no estatales
el autodenominado estado islámico atacó
lugares emblemáticos en irak y siria
ciudades como alepo racca mosúl y
especialmente palmira fueron objetivos
del grupo ofensivas premeditadas y
registradas como propaganda que sirven
de cortina a una financiación ilícita
mediante el tráfico de pequeñas piezas
en buena medida de la amenaza terrorista
se desprende que el 40% de la lista de
patrimonio mundial en peligro de la
unesco sea integrada por lugares del
mundo árabe y que el 30 se concentre en
áfrica para crear un marco de protección
del patrimonio se han adoptado diversas
normativas que van desde la convención
de la haya de 1954 hasta las
resoluciones 21 99 y 23 47 del consejo
de seguridad de la onu y en 2016 un
juicio en la corte penal internacional
de la haya por primera vez la
destrucción patrimonial con los crímenes
de guerra abriendo la puerta de
reconstrucciones aunque no bastan para
combatir el tráfico cultural sirven de
guía a asociaciones como la alianza
internacional para la protección del
patrimonio en zonas de conflicto que
desde 2016 ha protegido o rehabilitado
125 sitios en 25 países
a veces intervenimos en terrenos en los
que la violencia del conflicto fue tal
que las comunidades tuvieron que huir
dejando atrás su patrimonio es donde ha
dejado la marihuana pero una lucha más
amplia y mayores controles son
necesarios ya que como advierte de aliph
el patrimonio está cada vez más en
peligro
además del diplomático valley y freeland
hoy es nuestro invitado francisco gracia
alonso que será de guía en lo que ya de
aman crímenes de guerra francisco es un
placer saludarle hoy y también
preguntarle quién motiva o se busca con
esta limpieza cultural como dice la
unesco
muy diferentes motivos el primero de
ellos es crear un discurso
histórico para un determinado país en
determinado durante un determinado
periodo cronológico el que esté de
acuerdo con la conceptuación político
ideológica de sus gobernantes e intentar
eliminar cualquier tipo de rastro que
haga referencia a otras identidades
culturales otras formas de pensamiento y
de la misma forma también se conseguiría
mediante esa eliminación introducir una
serie de piezas la serie de bienes
muebles dentro del tráfico ilegal de
obras de arte para obtener recursos
económicos es lo que vimos que ha
sucedido durante las guerras de irak y
en principio también se llevó a cabo
durante la primera fase del gobierno
talibán lo veremos más adelante en
cuanto al tráfico de bienes ilícitos
pero también comentábamos que esto no es
un hecho excepcional pero en que es a
diferencia de las destrucciones del
pasado reciente y de la antigüedad
y la destrucción de obras de arte es
algo que podemos ver como usted bien han
dicho desde el período
sumerio desde los imperios mesopotámicos
desde el ámbito de lo que sería el
saqueo de bienes culturales en grecia y
roma y lo que posteriormente hasta hasta
la actualidad en que se diferencia la
diferencia en el hecho de la forma en la
cual se está concibiendo en la
destrucción porque lo que se pretende es
utilizar los medios de comunicación
utilizar la idea de la destrucción para
lanzar un mensaje tanto a los miembros
de la propia facción ideológica al cual
corresponden los destructores como al
resto de la
humanidad al resto de los de los short
de los países las entidades culturales
caso de la unesco por ejemplo de los
países occidentales para definir esa y
marcar una clara diferencia conceptual
entre la forma de concebir la sociedad
por parte en este caso
el gobierno talibán o bien de los grupos
como el isis respecto de la
conceptuación que podemos tener en el
ámbito del mundo occidental de lo que
significa la preservación del patrimonio
histórico arquitectónico y arqueológico
como un elemento que no representa
únicamente a una a un estado oa un grupo
social sino que es un elemento que forma
parte del acervo cultural de la
humanidad por tanto el concepto de
preservación es un elemento que va
ligado a nuestra propia esencia como
como individuos como como seres humanos
como seres que tienen un concepto muy
claro de lo que significa el patrimonio
y precisión de conservación y por otra
parte nos enfrentamos ante personas
grupos y estructuras políticas que
consideran que justamente su ideología
política y lo diga el mensaje que
quieren transmitir pasa por la
destrucción y no por la conservación
real nos habló también precisamente de
una mayor conciencia internacional sobre
el patrimonio escuchemos hay una toma de
conciencia internacionales sobre el
patrimonio que ella es importante hoy
que hace 20 años
esta conciencia es esencial porque si en
esta conciencia política no hay recursos
financieros buenas y que el patrimonio
incluso haciendo milagros con bajos
presupuestos requiere dinero y
en la actualidad uno de los desafíos es
que los recursos de la comunidad
internacional sean dirigidas en una
parte al patrimonio para protegerlo
quiero también hacer vivir los hombres y
mujeres de alrededor no existe
un equilibrio séptimo comparte francisco
que llama conciencia de que todos
perdemos algo en estas destrucciones
por supuesto él forma parte de nuestra
herencia cultural la herencia cultural
no es una herencia cultural de un estado
o de una región es una es una herencia
cultural universal todos los elementos
que configuran el pasado de la de la
humanidad desde la prehistoria hasta el
elemento hasta el presente que forman
parte de esos de ese conocimiento forman
parte de la forma en la cual se ha ido
construyendo la estructura de las
sociedades en su pensamiento la forma de
entender es su vida cotidiana a la forma
de entender en su relación con
principios ideológicos con estructuras
religiosas la forma de comunicarse entre
los miembros de una misma sociedad y con
otras sociedades por tanto cada elemento
que perdemos es una parte de nuestro
pasado que no va a ser posible recuperar
y lo que tenemos que hacer es justamente
profundizar en la investigación
profundizar en el desarrollo del
conocimiento
cuanto más profundo si ese conocimiento
mejor entenderemos las diferentes fases
culturales cronológicas etc que nos han
llevado hasta hasta el presente y
destruir es siempre perder un elemento
esencial de lo que somos como grupo
humano se cifran en miles los bienes
robados saqueados y bajo ese tráfico qué
consecuencias tiene perder el rastro y
qué a qué financiación sirven
el concepto de la entrada de miles de
bienes muebles dentro del tráfico ilegal
de obras de arte
significa un problema esencial porque no
ex no habría un vendedor si no existiese
un comprador el problema esencial radica
en que existe un mercado
en parte ilegal pero lo que es más grave
es que en muchas ocasiones es un mercado
legal que de obras de arte que asume las
piezas procedentes del saqueo las citas
procedentes del expolio de los museos
las piezas procedentes de la destrucción
de yacimientos arqueológicos que después
de ser blanqueados en lo que denominamos
como los puertos francos algunos de
ellos ubicados en diferentes países
europeos
una vez blanqueadas esas piezas en
cuanto a su origen pasan a formar parte
de lo que podríamos denominar el
comercio legal de obras de arte y de
hecho hay muchas piezas a las cuales se
sigue en la actualidad su rastro para
poder ver cómo han acabado en
colecciones privadas o incluso han
podido acabar en colecciones públicas
no hemos de olvidar que tenemos un caso
europeo tenemos un amplio
pasado de saqueo y destrucción de obras
de arte y que corresponde a las dos
guerras mundiales y el que corresponde
también a los diferentes conflictos
se han sugerido sobre el territorio
europeo pero también hemos de ver cuál
sea cuál ha sido la exportación ilegal
de obras de arte como consecuencia de
los procesos coloniales que han nutrido
los xolos en buena parte las colecciones
de los museos e norteamericanos sobre
los museos europeos y de los cuales
ahora en la actualidad sólo una pequeña
parte de los mismos empieza a formar
parte de las devoluciones acordadas
entre los estados que son continuadores
de las estructuras sociales que
generaron esta producción de obras
artísticas y los estados receptores por
diferentes motivos que los han mantenido
sus presiones públicas con este panorama
y para finalizar francisco se puede
hablar de un terrorismo transnacional o
genocidio cultural brevemente
por supuesto el concepto del genocidio
cultural significa la desaparición de la
memoria colectiva de las comunidades y
esto es lo que está sucediendo es decir
los elementos que nosotros podemos
calificar como piezas artísticas como
bienes muebles no son únicamente el
resultado de una expresión artística son
el resultado de un concepto de
pensamiento por parte de los grupos
sociales que
desarrollaron unas determinadas formas
de expresión artística para plasmar su
propio pensamiento lo que nos importa
cuando analizamos las obras de arte no
es el elemento tangible nosotros no son
sus elementos formales y decorativos
sino son los elementos intangibles el
pensamiento lo que hay detrás en la la
forma de comprender el mundo que ha dado
como origen el hecho de que determinadas
piezas estén realizadas bajo unas
determinadas características y sobre
todo el impacto social y la forma de
empleo de esos materiales dentro de la
estructura social que los produjo por
tanto si perdemos las piezas también
perdemos la posibilidad de analizar los
componentes sociales que origen a las
mismas y eso es gravísimo ha sido un
placer conversar con usted
francisco gracia alonso muchísimas
gracias por haber estado y a ustedes
muchísimas gracias los invitamos a más
cultura en france 24 y france24 punto
con gracias
[Música]